hello everyone and welcome to another
game from round one of this year's video
World Cup I I checked out a lot of games
and I thought this one was the most um
fitting to to show you as it's it
features a great fight and you guys will
enjoy the lines featured in this game uh
the game is played uh between uh
International master from Namibia Dante
belkish and of course even charge from
Croatia he's a very well-known uh
Grandmaster former 2700 he's also on the
team of Magnus Carlsen uh helping him
prepare for for his games so uh
definitely a tough opponent for any
player uh let alone an international
Master you can see the the rating
differences uh over 400 rating points
and
um uh we we don't know a lot about the
Dante but I I did find out that in 2017
he was both a Junior and senior champion
of Namibia and that is the first time
that that ever happened so now he's an
international Master uh hunting for his
Grandmaster Norms let's see how he did
in this game so Dante has the white
pieces and he opens with E4 of course we
already know even goes for the Sicilian
Defense pretty much exclusively Knight
F3 D6 and D4 now going for the open
Sicilian characters captures with Knight
to F6 and now Knight to C3 and now not
the deniter which is the absolute top
move here G6 the dragon the second most
popular option uh we have the saving the
the third most popular option but no
that's the fourth most popular Knight
the C6 is the classical Sicilian third
most popular and this is what even goes
for it so those are basically the top
four moves you will have in this
position there are other moves you can
play pretty much anything here but those
are the top ones uh so Bishop to G5 the
famous Arista Rouser attack and Ponte E6
with Queen D2 A6 and now castles Queen
side so of course we're gonna have a a
race here even most likely will Castle
uh King side or maybe even keep the king
in the center of the board and he will
start attacking on the queen side so
Bishop to D7 we have pawned the F4 and
now Pawn to B5 we have A3 stopping B4 uh
and Rook the B8 even simply prepares it
and uh this position has been reached
before and interestingly uh mostly by
Croatian Grandmaster Darko Darko felita
had his positions dankookozo had this
position even charge now has it and um
uh there are a couple of moves that were
tried in this position but we have
Knight to F3 and now Pawn to B4 opening
up the B file a captures Rook captures
and now there is a game where Queen the
ethi was played but here we have Pawn to
E5 and it is now as of move 13 that we
have a completely new game so obviously
the Knight cannot move the queen would
uh would hang so even Place Queen to A5
and now what's the idea can the Knight
be captured of course not you can see
that uh White will just get checkmated
here
be one in Queen captures and B2 will be
Checkmate so first king to B1 it's a
must must play Move uh D captures an E5
by even and now uh what do you play here
such a such a wonderful position if you
could only play Queen captures on D7
that would be Checkmate so why not just
remove the defender and deliver
Checkmate well the problem is if you do
this notice that the dark Square Bishop
has also uh been made available uh uh
here even with just play Rook capture
some B2 check and after King captures
Bishop to A3 check and now you are
either get checkmated if you go King B1
then a queen B4 check followed by Queen
to B2 Checkmate or if you go to A1 then
Bishop C1 opens up a discovery on the
White Queen White loses the queen and
there is no more Checkmate and of course
black wins because black will be up too
much material so here we have Knight the
A2 attacking the rook and this is
basically where the attack
uh ends and we go straight into the end
game and you have to play like this
otherwise black will just Crush you so
Rook to A4 offering a queen trade Queen
characters real characters and now F
captures on E5 attacking the Knight but
luckily now the Knight can move 94
threatening Knight to F2 to pick up one
of the Rooks and the bishop back to E3
guarding the F2 Square Bishop to E7 even
also uh read the castle and now Bishop
to D3 attacks the Knight Knight to C5
and of course Bishop to C4 you do not
want to capture you still have the
bishop pair so of course you wanna keep
it we have rooked A4 and now Pawn to B3
defending the bishop and also chasing
away The Rook uh The Rook doesn't really
have all that many squares and you don't
want to play something like Rook to E3
then Bishop to C1 can be played so even
just did what he was planning to do all
along and he sacrifices The Exchange to
mess up Dante's Pawn structure and to go
for the white king and also this gives
you a past a pawn so if you can uh maybe
castle for The Rook on A8 start pushing
that pawn the knights the Bishops are
here could be very good so Knights the
A5 going after the C4 pawn and Dante
defends it Rook to D4 we have castles
and now Knight to C3 uh Rook the C8 and
now Rook H to D1 also Bishop to G5 can
be considered the just trading of the
dark Square Bishops but here we have the
doubling of Rooks and the D file and now
Bishop to C6 as a rook captures Bishop
is the next move so Bishop to C6 and now
Knight to E1 we have Pawn to F6 even
would very much enjoy if this happened
then his Bishop would assume this
diagonal uh Bishop to F4 and now
uh you could uh you could also consider
something like Bishop to E8 the G6 to
put the bishop on this diagonal uh even
decides to play Knight to A4 he wants to
trade Knight and activate his Bishop
this way so okay Knight captures with
Bishop captures and now Pawn to C5 made
possible by the bishop being an A4 as
now the bishop is hanging so Bishop to
B5 and now Knight to D3 and what is the
uh the idea here uh even is already down
the exchange and even though he could
win this Pawn it's not it's not the best
for example Bishop captures Knight
captures Rook captures uh e captures on
F6 G captures and now you would get
something like sorry Rook to d8 with
check and after the king moves the
bishop to D6 and now the the idea is of
course we will put the bishop on F1 at
some point if we can also Rook to f8 is
an idea so what do you do with the Rook
you could even set a little trap Rook to
C4 even allow Rook to F1 to go after the
F6 Pawn uh Rook captures on C2 now opens
up a discovery on The Rook Rook captures
than F6 King captures King captures and
you trade down into this where even
would be up a pawn but the Dante would
still be up the exchange and it would be
Dante who would be playing for the for
the win here so it's not not the best of
course uh just uh taking a material so
even has to play for activity he still
has the bishop pair he has the past a
pawn he needs to stabilize and advance
that pawn all the way so here he pushes
F5 he keeps the position closed uh
Bishop to E3 and now Knight the C4
putting pressure on the bishop on E3
Bishop to F2 and now Pawn to G5 he wants
to get the pawns rolling on the king
side as well King the A2 and now King to
F7 and Dante plays King back to B1 he
says all right I'm just gonna wait and
see what he what you plan on doing King
to G6 and now Pawn to H4 we have Pawn to
H6 G4 and even advances the pawn all the
way to F4 so this is now also a pass
pawn bishop to G1 and now King back to
F7 with Bishop to F2 King to G7 and
Bishop to G1 so Dante happy with a draw
here even is not he goes Knight to A3
with check King to B2 and now Knight
back to C4 with check King to C1 and now
uh if he wants to continue the game he
has to play something either A5 or the
move that he went for Knight the E3 with
check which kinda messes up your Pawn
structure but uh even does of course
have an idea behind it Bishop captures
Pawn captures and now Pawn to H5 you
could also capture but then you uh
really make this bishop come alive so
Dante closes the king Side Pawn to H5
and now Pawn to E2 uh the idea being
that once The Rook moves even will
capture on C5 which he did Knight
captures Rook captures and now King to
D2 so the pawn on E2 is defended it's a
beautiful pass pawn and now even also
has a past a pawn that he can push and
here we have Rook to D5 even offers a
trade of Rooks and how would you
evaluate this position What would you do
here such a such a tricky position to
play where white is up material but you
just don't feel like you're up material
what would you play here such a such a
tricky tricky position uh even even feel
free to pause the video what would you
play here
foreign
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it and by do it I mean look 50 moves
ahead and find the solution
congratulations and for those of you who
just won't enjoy the show it is a rook
characters on D5 this is the only move
that gives uh White to the advantage and
it's such a difficult move to find
because after Rook characters on D5 and
E Capture Sun D5 this was not play the
game this is a hypothetical line the
only move that gives you the advantage
is C4 and if you don't find this uh
you're just not gonna be able to to find
all of this now the point is of course
if Pawn captures then the king can
capture and you get rid of the E2 pawn
and if the bishop captures you play Rook
B1 of course you want to infiltrate
Black's position and you want to go
after those King side pawns so Bishop B5
now you play Rook C1 again you wanna
infiltrate Bishop to C4 and now Rook to
C3 and now you gain access to F3 and the
black's position so here you have two
options if you play King F7 then the
immediate Rook F3 check and after King
if King the GC 7 of course the past Pawn
just wins so you're gonna have to play
King to E6 but then Rook F6 check
characters root captures on H6 and then
you have the past H Pawn and your
position will be winning so the absolute
uh best move for black here is to start
advancing the pass Pawn not move the
king and now it's very very tricky Rook
E3 attacks the Pawn King F7 uh Rook to
F3 back with check of course you do not
want to see this Pawn uh go down for
nothing King E6 Rook to F6 would check
King captures on E5 but now it's a
little bit different because your Pawn
is one a step further to queening Rook
captures than H6 Now Pawn to A4 Rook the
h8 pawn to A3 Rook to A8 and now Pawn to
A2 now look at this even would have a
pawn and 8 to end on E2 but uh both of
the squares are protected the King guard
Z1 The Rook guards A1 and also the Rook
guards the queening square which is a
dark square and the light Square Bishop
cannot do anything about it look at this
H6 King F6 H7 uh seems like you're
you're dead lost here but you can try
one more trick a queen you want check
King captors now A1 Queen check you have
to force the Rook to move back from the
back rank King the G7 and now Rook the
A7 with check you save the pawn and
after King to h8
uh you go Rook to D7 and now finally
there is no more way for black to play
this you can't push you can't do
anything you have to go after this Pawn
but then just the road captures Bishop
captures and Rook captures on G5 and of
course rook and pawn versus uh Bishop uh
completely winning for white so uh all
in all after Rook to D5 Rook captures
and D5 followed by C for the absolute
best for white but he played Pawn to C4
it's not a not an easy uh solution to
spot King to F7 and now Rook the C1
preparing Pawn to C4 uh King to E7 you
can you still cannot play this as
um of course The Rook would hang with
check so King the E1 and now Rook
captures on E5 we have Pawn to C4 now
adanta is advancing his past C Pawn uh
Bishop to C6 and now Rook the C3 we have
Pawn to A5 and pawn to C5 very nicely
placed it's on a dark Square so you
don't have to worry about the light
Square Bishop on the A4 with Rook to D6
going after the bishop and the bishop a
D5 we have rooked A6 putting the Rook
behind the pass pawn and Rook the E for
simply defending and putting pressure on
the G4 pawn and here we have Pawn to C6
and this is uh not the absolute best way
to proceed uh of course Dante was very
low on time here even had I think over
an hour so it wasn't a problem for him
but Dante was already down to his last
minute he does have the increment but
still you have to constantly make the
absolute best move and here one little
check makes all the difference it forces
the king back as now the D6 square is
still uh covered by the pawn so you have
to play something E8 or D it doesn't
really matter now you play C6 and now
it's very much different if Rook
captures
uh sorry if Rook to C4 which is kind of
the only way to defend this you will
play real characters Bishop captures and
now Rook the A8 with check with D7 and
d8 covered now once the king moves you
play C7 and now there is no uh way to
stop promotion you have to play
something like Bishop day6 but then of
course you you can see that it's lost
however after C6 this does give a give
even a chance to to bounce back Rook
captures and now C7 is not as powerful
now C7 is met with this look at this
beautiful move Bishop to C4 this is what
even found and this is what uh makes
this uh a problem because now of course
you cannot capture The Rook covers that
and if you bring a Queen into the game
then Rook the G1 check King death 2 or
D2 doesn't really matter you promote it
to your queen king to C2 and now Queen
to E2 will be Checkmate so big big
problem for uh for uh for him after uh
this Rook captures on G4 move if you
don't have C7 you have nothing so he
does go Rook to A7 check now but now
it's it's it's very much different King
38 and now you could capture he goes
King to F2 capturing is still the the
way to maybe fight for Advantage but now
even just place it Rook to E4 now he's
threatening promotion so King back D1
and King the C8 and now there is no more
way to push for the win here Rook to A8
with Chuck King C7 Rook E7 check King to
C8 even of course I'm very happy with
the draw here that he saved a game like
this and the Dante uh although he's
still he's still better but he doesn't
want to overpress his Advantage
otherwise he might just lose so he
decides to call it a day and he will try
tomorrow with the black pieces to take
even down uh in the in the uh second
game rookie seven checking C8 rookie
checking to C7 rookie seven check and he
was in this position and move 64. yes on
move 64 as as it always should be that
Dante bilkish and even charge agreed to
a draw as there is nothing more to be
done here so brilliant brilliant game by
both of them even really went for the
attack on the on the queen side
with the black pieces Dante defended he
went for the uh for for the uh early uh
in the game and a beautiful end game did
he play even uh tried a bit too much he
didn't want to draw then he over pushed
then Dante punished him but he just
couldn't find um some of the lines that
were crucial to winning this game uh
like I said he was down to a minute for
for the better part of the uh end game
Essence uh you've seen just how much it
takes to calculate all of this uh so
yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it we're probably gonna uh
continue with round two if there's like
a brilliant brilliant game that I've
missed of course I'm going to show it
but probably after we check out the
other games of the of the World Cup uh
so you know you do use that hashtag
suggestion I would like to thank
Christoph Mark old games are best Lane
Herbert said Harper and schlurture for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the video World Cup until it
finishes uh so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day and if you still haven't tried
our app for improving it cheers the
improve uh first link in the description
below do check it out or we have a we
already have over uh 10 000 people
trying it out so do check it out and if
you like it we would very much
appreciate it if you leave us a comment
or even a rating on the uh on the app
store or Play Store so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day